.
* Fliessende Klänge *
Noch heute leben viele wilde Mustangs
in ihrer natürlichen Umgebung
im weiten Norden Amerikas.
Doch der
immer knapper werdende Lebensraum
hat schwerwiegende Folgen.
Immer mehr Mustangs
werden eingefangen
und in Auffanglager gesperrt,
wo sie entweder als Reittiere
verkauft werden
oder auf dem Schlachthof enden.
Einige Wildpferde
schaffen es in eine Auswahl
und nehmen an einem
jährlichen Wettbewerb in Europa teil:
Dem Mustang-Makeover-Wettbewerb.
Dabei haben ausgewählte Pferdetrainer
und -trainerinnen 100 Tage Zeit,
einen wilden Mustang
aus den Tiefen Nevadas zu zähmen
und beim grossen Finale einer
renommierten Jury zu präsentieren.
Einer der Wettkampfteilnehmer
ist der Appenzeller Reittrainer
Walter Gegenschatz.
Wenn wir die Mustangs drüben fragen,
ob sie ins Flugzeug steigen,
rüberkommen und geritten werden
wollen, sagen sie: "Nein".
Sie wollen in der Prärie sein,
das ganze Land und die Natur haben.
Aber wir haben uns entschieden,
die Mustangs auszufliegen.
Wir haben uns entschieden,
die Mustangs zu reiten.
Es ist jetzt an uns,
ihnen zu vermitteln,
dass sie am Schluss
dieser Ausbildung,
am Ende jeder Session sagen können:
"Hm, vielleicht war es doch
keine so schlechte Idee."
Bitte hier noch unterschreiben.
Wir haben ihn angeschaut
und nicht gesehen,
dass er irgendeine Delle hat
oder ihm ein Bein fehlt.
Ja, ist gut.
Dann glaube ich dir das.
Als ich angefragt wurde, ob ich
an diesem Event teilnehmen möchte,
war ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Es gibt verschiedene Meinungen
zu solchen Events.
Ich unterhielt mich mit meiner Frau,
wir diskutierten und kamen
zum Schluss, dass wir mitmachen.
Wir nutzen diese Plattform
um aufzuzeigen,
was man erreichen kann
und was möglich ist,
wenn die Beziehung zum Pferd
an erster Stelle steht.
* Monotone Countryklänge *
Mein Name ist Walter Gegenschatz,
ich bin Parelli-5-Stern-Instruktor
Ich bin auf diesem Hof aufgewachsen.
Meine Eltern
hatten einen Milchviehbetrieb.
Als ich den Hof übernahm,
habe ich ihn zu einem
Pferdeausbildungsbetrieb umgestellt.
Wir bewirtschaften 25 ha,
wir produzieren das Heu
für unsere Pferde selbst.
Wir haben auf dem Betrieb,
je nachdem, wie viele Pferde
in Ausbildung sind, 20-25 Tiere.
* Geheimnisvolle Countryklänge *
Natural Horsemanship ist für mich
ein Umgang mit dem Pferd
auf eine natürliche Art und Weise.
Was ist natürlich für ein Pferd?
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Die Countrymusik verklingt. *
Der erste Tag der Challenge.
Walter Gegenschatz bringt
seinen wilden Mustang aus Nevada
auf seinen Reiterhof im Appenzell.
Ich wäre bereit,
ihr könnt aufmachen.
(Leise) Ho.
Hm? Willkommen im Appenzellerland.
(Leise) Gut, komm.
Ich glaube, sie wurden
hauptsächlich am Kopf berührt,
vielleicht wurde mal
am Hals gestreichelt, klar.
Aber viel mehr glaube ich nicht.
* Leises, sanftes Vogelzwitschern *
Ich finde Pferde faszinierend,
wie sie im Moment leben.
Sie leben nicht in der Vergangenheit
oder Zukunft.
Sie tun Dinge, die im Moment für sie
absolut logisch und sinnvoll sind.
Ob wir denken, dass es Sinn macht,
spielt keine Rolle,
sondern sie denken, dass man das
zum Überleben so macht. Punkt.
Gut.
Wirkt ganz zahm, nicht?
Aber das täuscht.
Das täuscht.
Hier auf seinem Reiterhof
im Appenzell
trainiert Walter Gegenschatz
alle seine Pferde
mit der sog.
Natural-Horsemanship-Technik.
Eine Technik, die sich mit
dem Wesen der Pferde auseinandersetzt
und die Verbindung zwischen Tier
und Mensch in den Vordergrund stellt.
Natural Horsemanship:
Dieses Wort muss man
mit Bindestrich schreiben.
Wir haben "horse",
das ist das Pferd,
wir haben "man", das ist der Mensch,
und wir haben "ship",
das ist symbolisch als Schiff
für eine gemeinsame Reise.
Jetzt hätten wir "horse-man-ship".
Dann stellen wir "natural" davor.
D.h., wir haben einen natürlichen
Umgang zwischen Pferd, Mensch,
Schiff - eben die gemeinsame Reise
auf eine natürliche Art und Weise.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge:
"Night Shift" von Tony Delmonte *
Ein natürlicher Umgang mit Pferden
ist für mich,
wenn man auf das Gegenüber eingeht.
D.h., auf die Bedürfnisse
des Pferdes einzugehen.
Wenn man lernt, zu verstehen,
wie ein Fluchttier funktioniert.
Walter hat mit dieser Technik
schon viele Pferde trainiert
und ist damit auch in offiziellen
Springreitturnieren erfolgreich.
* "Night Shift" spielt weiter. *
Gut, schauen wir mal, was wir
mit diesem Tier machen können.
Hey, boy.
Er reagiert schon. Gut.
Jetzt bin ich hier.
Jetzt honorieren wir das etwas.
Rohan, so heisst der wilde Mustang
aus Nevada,
ist jetzt schon fünf Tage
im Appenzell.
Bisher gab es nur kurze Interaktionen
zwischen Walter und ihm.
... und ich gehe etwas zurück.
Damit wir nicht nur hingehen,
sondern es eine Interaktion ist.
Hey, boy. Er reagiert schon.
Bis jetzt haben wir
nur solche Sachen gemacht.
Nur in der Form Kontakt aufgenommen,
dass er gibt, so viel er gibt.
Er kann bestimmen,
wie nahe er kommt,
wie viel er sich traut usw.
Wenn man seine Körpersprache
anschaut, sehen wir noch immer,
dass er mit relativ langem Hals
dieses Gras holt und frisst.
In seinem Kopf ist immer noch die
Bereitschaft für den Rückzug, weg.
Heute schauen wir,
ob ich ihn berühren kann.
Damit nicht nur er mich berührt.
Das Pferd hat eine persönliche Zone.
Bei ihm ist die noch relativ gross.
Und ich habe eine persönliche Zone.
Man könnte es auch
ein Energiefeld nennen.
Er hat ein Energiefeld
und ich habe eines.
Wenn ich hierher gehe ...
... traut er sich, herzukommen.
Wunderbar.
Aber wenn ich hingehe und ihn ...
Seht ihr,
das hat bereits eine Wirkung.
Die Energiefelder treffen sich
und haben einen Einfluss.
D.h., mein Arm ist zu kurz,
ich kann ihn nicht berühren.
Jetzt brauchen wir
eine Verlängerung.
Mal schauen, ob das reicht ...
... ob ich es damit kann.
Jetzt schauen wir,
ob ich ihn streicheln kann.
Aber ich kann ihn
nicht direkt streicheln,
d.h., ich berühre sein Energiefeld
oder seine persönliche Zone.
Dann beobachte ich
seinen Gesichtsausdruck.
Jawohl.
Das zeigt mir, wie gross
seine persönliche Zone ist.
Das geht.
Jetzt nähern wir uns an
und ziehen uns zurück.
Habt ihr gesehen?
Wenn ich ihm ins Gesicht schaue,
sehe ich, wo sein Bereich ist.
Wie nahe kann ich kommen?
Gut. Ich kann immer näher kommen.
Jetzt sagt er:
"Das ist ziemlich nahe."
Schauen wir, ob ich bleiben kann.
Jawohl, bis er sich entspannt.
Er orientiert sich an etwas anderem,
das ist ein Zeichen von Entspannung.
Gut, wieder näher,
er schaut in der Welt umher.
Er macht den Kontakt, gut.
Dann kann ich auch
den Kontakt machen.
Jawohl, gut. Ein erster Eindruck,
dann gehe ich wieder weg.
Guter Fury.
* Leises Schnauben *
Genau.
Das Pferd sagt schon lange etwas.
Und der Mensch reagiert nicht darauf
oder nimmt es nicht einmal wahr.
Ich kann ihn schon
ein wenig streicheln.
Ich kann den Stock verkürzen,
meine Hand kommt näher.
Gut. Er kommt sogar hinterher.
Ich zieh mich wieder zurück.
Ja, ja. Da ist das Limit.
Mal schauen, ob er's schafft.
Jawohl, sehr gut.
Diesmal muss er sich nicht
wegdrehen, also nicht ganz umdrehen.
Guter boy.
Wenn ich ihn am Hals streichle,
entspannt er sich.
Er schleckt sich über die Lippen,
eine ruhige, entspannte Session,
ein guter erster Eindruck.
Das lassen wir gut sein.
Good boy.
Walter lernte diese Natural-
Horsemanship-Technik in Amerika,
wo er mehrere Jahre bei
seinem Lehrer und Mentor Pat Parelli
lebte und arbeitete.
1997 sah ich Parelli zum ersten Mal.
An der Pferdemesse OFFA
in St. Gallen lief ein Video.
Ich lief daran vorbei, blieb stehen,
sah das und war beeindruckt,
was die Person auf dem Video
mit dem Pferd machte.
Ich dachte:
"Wow, das möchte ich auch können."
Ich ging dann vier Jahre
nach Amerika,
ich wurde von Pat
zu ihm auf die Ranch eingeladen.
(Englisch)
* Unbeschwerte Gitarrenklänge *
Gründer des ganzen Systems
war Pat, the horseman.
Ursprünglich ist er kein Cowboy,
er möchte sich
nicht als Cowboy bezeichnen,
sondern er ist ein horseman,
ein Pferdemensch.
Linda, die Lehrerin, die Psychologin
mit der Fähigkeit,
auf Gefühle und Bedürfnisse
anderer Menschen einzugehen.
Das Einzigartige am Parelli-System
ist sicher das Lernsystem.
Dass es vermittelbar ist,
dass Menschen es lernen können,
auch wenn man nicht im Pferdestall
auf die Welt gekommen ist.
Pat ist für mich ein grosser Mentor,
ein Vorbild.
In diesen Jahren,
als ich drüben war,
hatte ich sehr viel Zeit und
Möglichkeiten, um ihn zu beobachten.
Zum einen im Umgang mit Pferden,
zum anderen, wie er unterrichtet.
Wenn ich in der Schweiz
oder zu Hause unterrichte,
benutze ich ganz viele
Redewendungen, die er auch anwendet.
Manchmal denken die Leute,
es sei von mir.
Aber ursprünglich
ist es natürlich von Pat.
* Ruhige Musik *
Über die Jahre hat Walter den Hof
zu einer modernen
und pferdegerechten
Reitsportanlage ausgebaut.
Guten Morgen.
Er hat mehrere Mitarbeiter/-innen,
darunter seine Frau Barbara
und seine Eltern Ursi und Ueli.
Du kannst Mama beim Misten helfen,
dann hängen wir die Seilwinde an
und schneiden die Stauden ab.
Man muss das Doppelrad
noch montieren.
Ah, vielleicht, gell, ja.
Sally und Nadine, ihr könnt nach dem
Stallen auch runterkommen zum Helfen
und die Stauden zurechtziehen.
* Walter lacht. *
Die voralpine Lage im Appenzell
beschert dem Hof
nährstoffreiche Heuwiesen.
Optimale Futterreserven also für
die verschiedenen Pferde auf dem Hof:
Jungpferde, Ausbildungspferde, aber
auch Pferde mit Verhaltensproblemen.
Ihre Betreuung ist die finanzielle
Grundlage für Walter und sein Team.
Doch das war nicht immer so,
denn ursprünglich
waren seine Eltern Milchbauern.
* Ruhige Musik *
(Frau) Das ist sein Betrieb, wir
unterstützen ihn und helfen ihm,
wo wir können.
Wir freuen uns,
wie der Hof weitergeführt wurde.
Das musste nicht mit Kühen sein,
obwohl du
ein überzeugter Milchbauer warst.
Aber nichts ist für die Ewigkeit.
Es ist gut so, wie es jetzt ist.
* Ruhige Klänge *
* Leises Schnauben *
Wir hatten auch immer
die Liebe zu den Tieren.
Wir betrieben Landwirtschaft
und freuten uns an den Tieren.
Auch wenn eine Kuh ein kalbte -
ich habe hier kein Foto -,
dann waren wir zu viert dabei
und freuten uns am Kälbchen.
So wuchsen sie auf. Das ist gut.
Ja, ja.
* Geschirr klappert. *
Ich lege noch die Gabel dazu.
Segne Herr, was deine Hand
uns in Gnaden zugewandt.
Wir danken dir, Amen.
Amen.- Ich wünsche euch
einen guten Appetit.
Danke.
- Vielen Dank. Bedient euch.
Ich nehme zuerst Salat.
Er ist nicht schlecht,
aber nicht gleich wie das.- Mhm.
Walter stürmte immer,
dass er ein Pferd möchte.
Irgendwann sagten wir,
wenn sich die Gelegenheit ergibt,
kaufen wir ihm eines,
weil er sich so daran freute.
Dann musste ich in Rehetobel,
im Nachbardorf, eines suchen.
So holte Ueli mit dem Traktor
und dem Viehanhänger
und mit Walter natürlich das Pferd.
So war das. Walter war damals elf.
Schau mal hier.
Ich glaube, dass mir der Umgang
mit den Pferden auch sehr viel
im Umgang mit Menschen half.
Die Beziehungsgrundprinzipien
sind genau die gleichen.
Es ist ein Mit- und Füreinander.
Es ist eine Investition
in die Beziehungen.
Was kann ich investieren,
das den Umgang
mit anderen Menschen vereinfacht?
Es ist ein Verstehen des Gegenübers.
Wie funktioniert,
wie tickt mein Gegenüber,
damit ich verstehen kann, warum er
sich so oder anders verhält.
Mittlerweile ist Rohan
schon zwei Wochen
auf dem Reiterhof im Appenzell.
Walter und er konnten sich
schon ein wenig anfreunden.
Bereits mein erster Eindruck war,
dass er sehr überlegt ist
und sehr schnell lernt.
Er ist sehr denkend unterwegs.
Jawohl.
Gut.
Schau, er geniesst es schon fast.
Siehst du das?
Cool.
Er sagt: "Das ist cool,
der Mensch ist nicht schlecht."
In diesem System steckt eine
extreme Persönlichkeitsentwicklung.
Der Pferdeteil ist ein ganz
untergeordneter oder kleiner Teil.
Es geht eher um
die eigene persönliche Entwicklung.
Wer werde ich? Wer bin ich?
Wie bin ich,
wie wirke ich auf mein Pferd?
Was für einen Einfluss habe ich?
Wie beeinflusst meine Persönlichkeit
mein Gegenüber?
* Sanftes Schnauben *
Wir lassen ihn hier etwas erkunden.
Etwas auskundschaften.
* Walter seufzt. *
Es ist eine Selbstreflexion.
Es ist merken oder wissen,
was man ausstrahlt.
Wenn ich dafür Bewusstsein
erlangt habe, kann ich es verändern.
Dann kann ich sagen:
"Warte mal, ich muss etwas langsamer
oder etwas mehr auftreten,
oder ich wirke immer etwas
schüchtern oder sehr dominant."
Wenn ich weiss, wie ich wirke,
mich selbst reflektieren kann,
dann kann ich besser verstehen,
warum mein Gegenüber
sich so oder anders verhält.
Wir haben wieder etwas Skepsis.
* Unruhige Klänge *
Da zieht sich alles zusammen.
Jawohl.
Man sieht die Bauchmuskeln.
Gut, schauen wir, ob wir das
Publikum miteinbeziehen können.
Ihr könnt zu diesem Tor dort gehen.
Ganz natürlich,
wir beobachten seine Reaktionen.
Stehen bleiben,
wir lassen ihn verdauen.
Jawohl.
Gut, hüpft mal.
* Leises Lachen *
Das machen wir so lange,
bis er sich entspannen kann.
Wir machen
noch einen kleinen Versuch.
Und zwar mit Geräuschen.
Ich gehe wieder etwas weg, damit wir
einen schönen Abstand haben.
Dann könnt ihr applaudieren.
Ihr könnt etwas länger.
Noch mal.
Etwas lauter.
Gut.
Wunderbar.
Wir haben jetzt
ein kleines Publikum,
ich gehe davon aus,
dass es in Fehraltorf
zwei, drei Leute mehr sein werden.
Aber die Voraussetzungen sind da,
damit es ein erfolgreicher Tag wird,
und er mit der Situation dort
nicht überfordert ist.
Bis zum grossen Mustang-Finale
bleiben noch 83 Tage.
Walter nützt die Zeit,
um mit Rohan eine Pferdeshow
in Fehraltdorf zu besuchen.
Dort möchte er seine ersten
Fortschritte mit dem Mustang
vor einem Publikum präsentieren.
Wenn ich das einfach
für mich zu Hause mache,
dann würden sich meine Pferde freuen
und es wäre schön.
Aber es ist mein Naturell,
mitzuteilen oder zu teilen.
Wenn ich eine Erfahrung mache
oder etwas lerne,
drehe ich mich sofort um
und erzähle das weiter.
Das ist mein Naturell.
Es ist einfach cool, wenn
andere Menschen oder andere Pferde
von meinem Wissen oder
diesen Gedanken profitieren können.
Ich möchte meinem Pferd beibringen,
dass es den Menschen
akzeptieren kann.
Zuerst als Freund.
Der zweite Schritt ist dann, den
Menschen als Vorbild zu akzeptieren
oder als Alpha, als Leader.
Der dritte Schritt
ist das Akzeptieren des Sattels.
Der vierte Schritt
ist das Akzeptieren des Reiters.
Ich versuche,
in der Geschwindigkeit,
in der ich glaube,
ihn konfrontieren zu können,
vorzugehen.
Zum ersten Mal überhaupt
versucht Walter an dieser Show
seinem Mustang Rohan
auf den Rücken zu steigen.
Gar nicht so einfach:
Denn Wildpferde sind als Fluchttiere
sehr sensibel, gerade am Rücken.
In freier Wildbahn müssen sie sich
vor bedrohlichen Situationen
schützen,
z.B., wenn sie von Pumas oder Wölfen
angegriffen werden.
Dass Rohan Walter
ansatzweise aufsteigen lässt,
zeugt von grossem Vertrauen.
Nein, nein.
Ja, ja.
Du schafft es.
Genau.
Wir sind hier etwas im Clinch.
Wenn man auf ihn draufklettern kann,
gäbe es die Möglichkeit ...
... dass man behauptet ...
... das wäre gefakt.
Also, dass er schon geritten wurde.
Er wurde aber noch nicht geritten.
So weit hinten hat ihn
bestimmt noch niemand berührt.
Ich glaube, wir lassen das so.
Hammerpony.
Gut.
Ich glaube, ihr dürft applaudieren.
* Aufbrandender Applaus *
Ich würde sagen, wir nehmen ihm mal
diese Mustang-Schnur ab.
So.
Der Wechsel von Mustang
zu Reitpferd.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge:
"Night Shift" von Tony Delmonte *
Aha, du denkst, man kann sich
an einem solchen Fass gut kratzen?
* Schnauben *Er kann lernen,
mich mehr zu respektieren.
Jawohl.
Im Moment,
in dem ich das Gefühl habe,
dass er sich damit auseinandersetzt,
wie jetzt,
lasse ich ihn in Ruhe,
ich nehme den Druck weg.
Zu verschied...
... zu verschiedenen Objekten gehen.
Er kommt auf die verschiedenen Si-
tuationen und Herausforderungen zu,
und fragt sich,
was man mit dieser Situation macht.
Ein Nein wäre,
dass er damit ein Problem hat,
damit nicht umgehen kann
und in die andere Richtung rennt.
Er sieht das Problem -
bei ihm ist es beeindruckend,
wie er immer nach Lösungen sucht,
nicht nach Problemen.
Gut.
Du bist ein Hammerpony.
Ich würde sagen, du bist bereit.
Dir kann man einen Sattel auflegen.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Und es macht keinen Unterschied.
Es ist schon verrückt,
dass man diese Pferde
über die ganze See fliegt,
von Amerika hierher,
für eine solche Veranstaltung.
Es gäbe in Europa genug Pferde,
die man retten oder reiten könnte
und mit denen man eine solche
Veranstaltung machen könnte.
Der Mustang oder ein wildes Pferd
hat einfach eine spezielle Magie
und zieht deshalb
ein grösseres Publikum an.
Das ist eine Gelegenheit,
um eine Botschaft zu vermitteln,
weil man ein grösseres Publikum hat.
Wie auch die Botschaft,
dass die Situation
der amerikanischen Mustangs
nicht die beste ist.
Für die Anzahl Pferde, die dort
sind, haben sie zu wenig Platz.
Deshalb müssen sie sie einfangen
und in Auffangstationen sperren.
Dort hat es Tausende Pferde,
die einfach dahinvegetieren.
Das ist keine würdige Situation,
das ist eine furchtbare Situation.
Darauf aufmerksam machen zu können,
finde ich einen wichtigen Punkt.
Wie viel man am Schluss
verändern kann, weiss ich nicht.
Das liegt
bei höheren politischen Gremien.
Aber man muss das versuchen, etwas
tun und auf die Situation hinweisen.
* Unruhige Gitarrenklänge *
So.
Gut.
Das ist ja Wahnsinn.
Vorne auch.
Hinten und vorne.
* Dunkle Gitarrenklänge *
Hast du gesehen? Er ist lahm.
Ich habe es gesehen.
- Ja.
Vielleicht Arthrose oder ...
... oder muskulär.
Sehnentechnisch.
Das kam schon von einem Moment
auf den anderen.
Und jetzt?
- Das weiss ich auch nicht.
* Beunruhigende Musik *
Den Kopf bitte etwas zu mir rüber.
Das ist seine rechte Seite,
die ist perfekt, alles picobello.
Und hier ist die ganze Spitze weg.
Ja, was kann man machen?
Man kann Entzündungshemmer geben
und ins Gelenk spritzen,
um die Entzündung wegzunehmen,
man kann den Nerv rausnehmen.
Nein, nein.
Ich zeige die Optionen auf.
- Ja.
Uns geht es darum, ob man
mit dem Tier weitermachen kann.
Das kann man klar nicht.
Was man macht,
das müssen Sie entscheiden.
Das Hufgelenk
ist ein sehr erhebliches Problem.
Das ist nicht unbedingt Schmerz,
sondern eher Druck.
Er ist nicht lahm, er hat Gleichge-
wichts- und Koordinationsstörungen.
Das ist gut. Nein, das ist schade,
das ist keine gute Diagnose.
Das tut einem leid.
Er hat so viel gelernt.
Cool eigentlich.
- Ja.
Nach Einschätzung des Tierarztes
muss sich Rohan
seine Verletzung am Hufgelenk
bereits in der Wildnis
zugezogen haben.
Er wird zwar wieder
normal laufen können,
aber seine Reitkarriere ist vorbei.
Ja, genau.
Und was passiert jetzt mit dir,
Kumpel?
Ich glaube, so wie das jetzt klingt,
wirst du von hier
auf eine Weide gehen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass du noch
irgendwelche grossen Aktionen,
grosse Shows machst. Aber das
ist dir ja ziemlich egal, nicht?
Was meinst du?
Jetzt müssen wir
in der Organisation schauen,
ob das auch mein Ende ist, ob das
Abenteuer auch für mich beendet ist.
Wenn man die ganzen 100 Tage
zur Verfügung gehabt hätte,
dann hätte man wahrscheinlich
ein relativ gut ausgebildetes Pferd
zeigen können.
Das ist ganz klar schade.
Dort war es schon wieder trocken.
Wenn du zu ihm auf die Weide gehst,
vielleicht ein paar Tipps
auch für dich zu Hause.
Jetzt z.B. ist er schon aufmerksam.
Das sind Kreise
seiner persönlichen Zone,
respektiere sie.
Guten Morgen.
Wunderbar, good boy.
Ja, ja. Alter Skeptiker.
Okay.
Ich habe mir noch nie überlegt,
ihn zu behalten.
Wir haben nicht wirklich
die Voraussetzungen,
wie sie sie
vielleicht in Deutschland haben.
Wo er wirklich
auf einer grösseren Weide
in einer grösseren Gruppe
rausgehen könnte.
Attaboy.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Guter Knabe.
Wenn er gesund wäre, dann wäre er
ein ganz interessantes Pferd.
Mach's gut.
Aber man muss sich bewusst sein,
was man mit Pferden machen möchte.
Ja, ja.
Dank einer Patenschaft
hat Rohan einen Weideplatz
in Deutschland bekommen,
wo er von nun an trotz seiner
Verletzung am vorderen Hufgelenk
ein würdiges Leben haben wird.
Super, viel Spass.
* Schnauben *
(Ursi) Er ist zielstrebig,
er weiss, was er will.
Das ist eine Stärke von Walter.
Es war ihm egal,
was die anderen Leute sagten.
Wenn andere Bauern mähten,
trainierte er zuerst
und ging dann nach Hause zum Mähen.
Es nicht sehr wankelmütig.
Er weiss, was er will und es ist
ihm egal, was die anderen sagen.
Eine positive Einstellung zu
behalten ist nicht jeden Tag gleich.
Manchmal haben wir
grosse Herausforderungen,
die es wirklich schwierig machen,
eine positive Einstellung
zu behalten.
Aber ... Wie soll ich sagen?
Am Schluss steht und fällt vieles
mit deinen Wurzeln
oder deinen Grundlagen.
Worauf ist dein Leben aufgebaut?
Was gibt dir Halt,
Zuversicht, Sicherheit?
In schwierigen Momenten
hilft ihm sein starker Glaube,
seine Verbundenheit mit Gott.
Das war eine Sache, die mich
von Anfang an sehr fasziniert hat.
Ich kannte das so nicht,
einen gelebten Glauben.
Das war sehr faszinierend.
Man muss üben,
positiv zu bleiben und zu denken.
Ein bisschen
muss es einem auch gegeben sein.
Ich als alte Skeptikerin weiss, dass
es manchmal nicht ganz einfach ist.
Bis zum grossen Finale in Aachen
in Deutschland
verbleiben noch etwas mehr
als drei Wochen.
Die Organisation
des Mustang-Makeover-Wettbewerbs
hat für Walter Gegenschatz
einen neuen Mustang gefunden.
Das Tier wurde zuvor von
einem anderen Teilnehmer betreut,
der sein Training
aber unverhofft abbrechen musste.
Damit bleibt Walter
also weiterhin im Rennen.
Diesmal mit der Mustang-Stute
Belleza.
Willkommen im Appenzellerland.
Ich habe mich entschieden,
mit Belleza wegen
der Herausforderung weiterzumachen,
solche Sachen reizen mich natürlich.
Ich habe drei Wochen,
das Pferd hat wahrscheinlich
noch nicht allzu viel gemacht.
Ich wusste,
dass wir damals in New Mexico
die wilden Mustangs aus der Prärie
nach vier Tagen ritten.
Nicht in einer Show oder
vor Publikum, aber wir sassen drauf.
Das wird wohl heissen,
dass ich in drei Wochen mit Belleza
noch das ein oder andere schaffe.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Hier hat es etwas Neues,
eine andere Situation.
Sie wird sich ein Herz fassen,
jawohl.
Gefühlsmässig ist es für sie, wie
wenn wir einen Pullover anziehen.
Es ist einfach
ein Ball auf dem Rücken.
Machen wir so, ganz fein am Zügel.
Wenn Sie mitkommt ist es gut,
wunderbar.
* Lockere Musik *
Und dann ist es endlich soweit:
Walter fährt mit seiner Mustangstute
Belleza nach Aachen -
ans grosse Mustang-Makeover-Finale.
* Wiehern *
Der Wettbewerb zieht jedes Jahr
viele Zuschauer an
und ist für Pferdekenner
ein bedeutender Anlass.
Aachen ist wahrscheinlich
für Pferdemenschen
wie Wimbledon für Tennisfans.
Es ist speziell, wenn man hier steht
und sich umsieht.
Ich jetzt kann sagen,
ich bin in Aachen geritten.
Nicht gerade im Grossen Preis
beim Springen,
aber das Mustang-Makeover
ist auch nicht schlecht.
Der Wettbewerb bietet v.a. eins:
Show und Spektakel,
Bier und Bratwürste.
Schnell wird klar: Hier steht
nicht nur das Pferd im Mittelpunkt.
Man muss ein gewisses Mass
an Publikum anziehen.
Ansonsten geht es wirtschaftlich
nicht auf, ganz klar.
Das Publikum besteht
nicht komplett aus Pferdemenschen
oder extrem pferdeinteressierten
Menschen.
D.h., sie sind an einer Show
interessiert.
Mit Spektakel, lauter Musik usw.
Den Spagat zu finden zwischen der
Bedürfnisbefriedigung des Publikums,
ohne dass man das Pferd
über eine Klippe stösst
und Prinzipien über Bord wirft,
ist sicher nicht immer ganz einfach.
(Kommentator) Es geht los.
* Spannende Musik *
Längst nicht alle Teilnehmenden
arbeiten nach der
Natural-Horsemanship-Methode
wie Walter Gegenschatz.
Während des Wettbewerbs können hier
unterschiedlichste Techniken
beobachtet werden.
Jetzt zeigt sich, welches
Trainingssystem am effektivsten ist.
(Kommentator) Die nächsten beiden,
die hereinkommen,
sind Wally Gegenschatz
mit Stiefel's Belleza.
* Vereinzelter Applaus *
* Spannende Musik *
Das Finale erstreckt sich
über drei Tage
mit mehreren Parcours und Aufgaben.
Am Ende entscheidet
eine internationale Jury
über die beste Darbietung.
* Akzentuierte Klänge *
In der Wildnis meiden Mustangs enge
und dunkle Höhlen ganz instinktiv.
Es könnten
sich Raubtiere darin befinden
und es gibt keine Fluchtwege.
Dass Belleza ihre Angst überwinden
kann und in den Anhänger steigt,
zeugt vom Vertrauen,
das sie in der nur kurzen Zeit
zu Walter aufbauen konnte.
* Lockere Countrymusik *
* Johlen *
Das ist nicht so mein Ding,
hier den grossen Zirkus zu machen.
Da fühlt man sich manchmal
etwas komisch.
Aber da muss man einfach mitspielen
in diesem Zirkus.
Wenn es sein muss, muss es sein.
Ich persönlich zeige lieber,
was mir wichtig ist und meine Werte.
Da ist das grosse Spektakel
nicht dabei.
* Jubel und Applaus *
Mein Ziel
in einer solchen Challenge ist,
dass das Pferd
eine gute Erfahrung macht.
Dass auch das Pferd
davon profitieren kann,
das ist mir wichtiger als
eine grosse Show oder Resultate.
Wenn das Hand in Hand geht,
wenn das Pferd
eine positive Erfahrung sammeln kann
und man gute Resultate bekommt, weil
die Beziehung auf diesem Niveau ist,
dann ist es super cool.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Mein Gedanke, nichts
am Seil zu machen, sondern frei,
ist, damit man es noch
offensichtlicher sieht.
Die Leichtigkeit, die Antworten,
wie wenig Aufwand es ist,
dass mein Pferd schneller, langsamer
läuft, die Richtung ändert.
Die Bindung,
mein Pferd bleibt nicht bei mir,
nur, weil ich ein Seil daran habe,
sondern es ist der freie Wille.
* Gefühlvolle Countrymusik *
Am Schluss ist es dem Pferd egal,
welchen Rang man hat.
Viel wichtiger ist die Erfahrung.
Von daher kann ich zufrieden sein,
es ist ein gutes Gefühl,
ich habe nichts erzwungen.
Ich habe sie nirgends
darüber gedrückt
oder mehr gemacht als
sie in diesem Moment geben konnte.
* Schnauben *
(Kommentatorin) Walter Gegenschatz
und Stiefel's Belleza.
Rang 6 für Walter Gegenschatz
und Belleza,
dafür, dass sie nur drei Wochen
gemeinsam trainieren konnten,
sicherlich ein beachtliches Ergebnis.
* Fliessende Musik *
Ich habe bei Pat sehr vieles
über Pferde gelernt.
Aber genau so viel über Menschen
oder mich selbst.
Die Selbstreflexion,
sich selbst zu sehen.
Ein wichtiger Punkt ist immer,
dass man sich selbst
nicht so wichtig nimmt.
Also, vielfach sieht man,
dass das eigene Ich sehr zentral ist
und alles ausfüllt.
Dann hat es für andere keinen Platz.
Je mehr Platz ich in der Zusammen-
arbeit mit Pferden und mit Menschen
oder auch in Beziehungen
für das Gegenüber habe ...
Wenn man es aus der Sicht
des Pferdes betrachtet,
was sind seine Bedürfnisse,
was kann ich tun,
um das Leben des Gegenübers
zu vereinfachen?
Das ist ein sehr zentraler Punkt
in dieser Lebensphilosophie.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Ein gutes Jahr später
ist Walter in Deutschland,
wo er einen alten Freund besucht,
der hier einen schönen Platz
auf der Weide gefunden hat
und seinen Ruhestand geniesst.
Sie sind da hinten auf der Weide?
- (Frau) Genau.
Sie geniessen ihr Leben.
Da siehst du die drei, vier schon.
Ja, schau, dort hinten.
- Genau.
Das ist mega. Ist er immer
mit seinen Kumpels zusammen?
Immer, er ist gut integriert.
Er ist die ruhende Seele
in unserer Herde -
ein ganz toller Bub.
- Cool.
Darf in reingehen und schauen?
- Bitte. Da bin ich gespannt.
Schau mal.
Cool, nicht?
Wie zufrieden sie
auf der Weide sind.
Sie haben es schön hier, Bäume,
Wind, frisches Gras, Wasser.
Kumpel ... Was will man mehr?
* Leises Vogelzwitschern *
Hey, boy.
Junge.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Gut.
Man sieht die Natur, man sieht noch
immer den Mustang in ihm, klar.
Er ist nicht einfach so blauäugig.
Es ist eine andere Situation
auf der offenen Weide.
Es ist schon einen Moment her, dass
wir etwas miteinander gemacht haben.
Schauen wir mal ...
... ob wir hier etwas machen können,
ob er sich traut,
in die Nähe zu kommen.
Traust du dich?
Jawohl, so ist's gut.
Fast wie am ersten Tag.
Attaboy, ja, ja.
So ist das ein Braver.
Brav. Ah, du bist immer noch
ein wenig ein Mustang.
Ja, ja.
Aber gut.
Du hast es super hier.
Hey, boy.
Hm, wie geht's dir?
Schau,
seine Augen entspannen sich schon.
Kannst du dich an mich erinnern,
Kumpel?
Hm?
Wir hatten doch eine coole Zeit.
Es war doch nicht so schlecht,
dass du in Amerika
in den Flieger gestiegen
und nach Europa gekommen bist.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Ja, ja.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Michaela Hoss - 2024